The world is full of secret, underground societies,
that operate in the shadows and meet behind
closed doors, in windowless rooms.
Some believe these societies are secretly
running the world.
Let's find out more about the organisations
that don't want to be found out.
1.
The Skull and Bones order is senior secret
society at Yale University in Connecticut,
it's members are called Bonesmen.
It was founded in 1832 and is still running
today.
Membership is restricted to only a few highly
elite individuals.
Members meet every Thursday and Sunday of
each week in a building called The Tomb.
Both of the Bush presidents were members of
the Skull and Bones society whilst studying
at Yale.
And the majority of its other members have
gone on to achieve great fame and fortune.
Numerous conspiracy theories surround the
group.
Some believe they are the American branch
of the infamous illuminati.
But the most popular theory is that the CIA
was formed by members from the Skull and Bones
society and that they still control the CIA
to this day.
2.
Next up is the Bilderberg Group, the name
for a secretive annual conference of approximately
150 highly influential individuals, membership
is strictly by invitation only.
Consisting of mostly prime ministers and presidents
from the most powerful countries in Europe
and North America, these make up two thirds
of the club's membership.
The other third of the members are said to
be major international bankers and media moguls.
The club meets every year at secretive locations
around Europe and America, what the group
discusses is kept top secret, but is believed
that they discuss how countries and major
organisations can better work together to
improve their economics and defence systems.
In other words they discuss how to run the
world more economically and efficiently.
Because of the secrecy of the group and the
high profiles of its members, the Bilderberg
Group is surrounded by controversy and conspiracy
theories.
3.
The Freemasonry organisation is a deeply historic
fraternity that can trace its roots back to
stonemasons in the early 17th century.
Freemasons meet regularly and are generally
focused on improving the lives of their members
and community, they also give heavily to charity,
despite this they are highly secretive.
Being such a historic organisation, Freemasons
perform various rituals during their meetings
and use secret signs and handshakes to recognise
fellow Masons.
Conspiracy theorists often link Freemasons
to groups such as the Illuminati, believing
that they are a contributing force to the
new world order.
4.
Next up is The Knight's Templar.
The Knight's Templar were a military order
setup by the Roman Catholic Church around
1129.
The group had a highly secretive initiation
ceremony.
Commonly adorned in distinctive white mantles
with a red cross.
They were the wealthiest and most skilled
fighters of all the Christian Crusades.
There were also non combatant members of the
Knight's Templar who were in charge of managing
the large economic infrastructure throughout
Christendom.
The organisation created financial techniques
that were the earliest forms of banking.
They also built many military fortifications
across Europe and the Holy Land.
One of the most famous legends is that the
illustrious Holy Grail and possibly the Ark
of the Covenant were discovered by the Knight's
Templar at Temple Mount.
5.
The Hashshashin were a mysterious group of
Muslim assassins that operated in the Middle
East during the 13th century.
The group was made up of Shia Muslims who
banded together in order to create a new utopian
state.
The group heavily used guerrilla tactics in
battles against their enemies, such as espionage,
sabotage and political assassination.
They worked by placing highly trained moles
inside enemy strongholds, and instructed to
only attack when the time was right.
It is reported that enemy leaders would awake
in the morning to find a Hashshashin dagger
lying on their pillow, along with a note saying
"you are in our grip."
The group became legendary contract killers.
Even performing jobs for high profile individuals
such as King Richard the Lionheart.
It is believed that the word "Hashshashin"
is where the modern word "assassin" comes
from.
6.
Founded in 1957, the Cadaver Society is a
secret society based at Washington and Lee
University in Lexington, Virginia.
The group is extremely secretive and it's
membership and organisational structure are
unknown.
The society must be very wealthy because it
has made numerous, substantial donations to
the University itself over the years.
It is rumoured that the Cadaver Society has
a network of underground passageways spanning
throughout the university campus.
It is believed the society uses these tunnels
to travel around the campus undetected.
There are peculiar small locked doors all
across campus that seem to support this theory,
such as this one in the Leyburn Library.
Some believe the Cadaver Society to be a branch
of the Illuminati.
7.
Next up is the Hermetic Order of the Golden
Dawn, not the catchiest name for a secret
society.
They were devoted to the study and practice
of the occult, metaphysics and paranormal
activity, and everything considered magical,
during the 19th and 20th centuries.
The order has been one of the single biggest
influences on 20th century Western occultism,
such as Wicca.
8.
Another infamous occultist organisation is
the Ordo Templi Orientis.
It is an international fraternal and religious
society, founded at the begging of the 20th
century.
It is dedicated to the Law of Thelema, which
was developed by the well known British writer
and occultist Aleister Crowley, who went by
the nickname of "Great Beast".
The organisation uses highly stylised rituals
for initiation.
During their meetings many Ancient Egyptian
Gods are invoked, as well as the Devil.
They are known for sometimes performing their
rituals completely naked.
The Ordo Templi Orientis claims to have over
3,000 members worldwide.
9.
Rosicrucianism is a philosophical secret society
founded in late medieval Germany around the
16th century.
Rosicrucians opposed Roman Catholicism, rejecting
the idea of Dogma and instead relying on evidence
and experience to form conclusions.
It is believed that the Rosicrucians were
one of the biggest influences on the creation
of Freemasonry.
It is also rumoured that Isaac Newton was
a member.
10.
And finally, is of course, the Illuminati.
Originally known as the Bavarian Illuminati,
they are a secretive group formed during the
age of enlightenment, on May 1st, 1776.
The Illuminati's original goals were to oppose
and put an end to superstition and religious
influence over public life.
They encouraged people to think for themselves
instead of doing what the state and their
religion tells them to do.
The Illuminati is made up of mostly atheists.
Naturally the Roman Catholic Church didn't
take too kindly to the formation of the group.
So in 1784 the illuminati, along with freemasonry
were outlawed by the Bavarian leader Charles
Theodore, with the encouragement of the Roman
Catholic Church.
However this didn't perturb the Illuminati,
they continued their meetings and pushing
their ideologies, but now all done in top
secret.
It is thought that, operating in the shadows,
and from behind closed doors, the Illuminati
were responsible for the French Revolution.
It is thought by scholars that the Illuminati
collapsed entirely in the late 1700s.
But some believe they are still very active
to this day.
And is secretly operating and managing the
major governments of the world and they seek
to create a One World Government based on
humanist and atheist principles.